you know the respect thing when you're
doing a kissing scene it's just like hey
i want to have you know first of all
have a breath mint don't have a tuna
sandwich before
uh you know before you kiss uh make sure
the person's comfortable
uh
do you but there's also
some come on
sometimes aren't you a little bit like
excited to kiss a certain person as
opposed to sometimes where you're like
oh this is work and then the other thing
is like this is good work
this is i'm getting paid to kiss selena
gomez yeah i think at the time though i
was so
because i think
because i think selena was with justin
at the time oh so that was an area that
i did not want to even like
interfere with
uh because i also really liked him too
and he used to come to set a lot was he
really nice really nice i played hockey
with him in a tournament and he was
really nice if the first thing he did
was walk up to me and goes hey how's the
girl on smallville was she cool lana
lange
yeah yeah yeah yeah she really he like
really was enamored by her yeah i liked
her we talked about that yeah he's a big
hockey yeah
yeah um so yeah no i think at the end of
the day
it's
you know
i look everyone's human like of course
like
if there's a beautiful human being like
okay this doesn't suck yeah it doesn't
suck but
with with selena particularly i wasn't
even i wasn't even thinking about it i
was genuinely thinking like
this is
this is her show right like i don't want
to it so you didn't even but but at the
end of the day did you walk offset in
your head just in like a young how old
are you so uh well because at that point
i think i was like 18 or nine okay so
let's see 18 year old walking off set
you just kissed selena gomez wasn't
there that kind of like
those lips were just
fluffy i was wonderful i was very um
what's the word um
i was i wasn't shy when i was 17
but i definitely wasn't extremely
confident
so so you didn't know if she even liked
kissing you
yeah i was just like did she ever say
something like hey good job no really
nice list that was an excellent kiss no
you never did that no i did that once
before where i'm like that was a great
kiss that i felt that that was real that
was
that i think we did had it look on
camera
that felt great did you did you did you
was that okay was my breath all right i
want to know these things you didn't you
never you never went there no i wanted
to keep my job you know i just always
wanted i wanted to get in do my job get
out
you know